when people make decisions and try to
look for who to blame i don't really
think it's right so and i always like
the narrow things to myself like i said
i've done
i've saved money put it into car
business
i lost
a lot of money there i think at fact i
think i had to clear about sea salt or
five vehicles when i wanted to close it
down and i had to sell another map at
half price
hey what's up welcome back to winners on
a wednesday where every single wednesday
at 7 p.m i interview one of my students
who is killing it in property and become
financially free as a result of my
training and techniques in this video
you're gonna hear from asita he is
absolutely incredible from nigeria now
living just outside london he's
financially free he came to me a couple
of years ago and he was working in a job
and he said to me samuel i haven't got
any more hours in the day i haven't got
time to do property what can i do and
he's managed to become financially free
got a nice portfolio of five rental
rents making him a profit of 3 000
pounds a month and he's just picked up
the keys to a property that he bought on
auction which is a buy refurbished
finance property and in this video
you're going to hear step by step
exactly how we did it so that you can do
the same thing too a seat firstly
massive congratulations my brother thank
you so much someone and i must thank you
especially for welcoming me to this
interview well i remember when we met
about two years ago and i said to you
the first time we met i said you're
going to be really successful you said
that's true yeah and here you are super
successful yes so what's the journey
what was it that initially pulled you to
property and what were the what were the
reasons and the excuses that you
couldn't be successful because i you
know it's very easy to find excuses yeah
and you were in a situation whereby it
would have been very easy for you to say
i can't do this so where were you at
when we first met good before again i go
into where i was before we first met i
would like to take this opportunity
first of all to thank you especially
i i want to thank you and you the
members of your team for what they did
for me during the training the knowledge
you guys provided the environment the
members of the academy i'm so proud of
of everything that i benefited from
because at the end of the day although
it seems as i've achieved this but it's
not my achievements a lot of these come
to get came together to support me
to bring me to where i am today but i
also want to take the opportunity to
especially thank my wife
she is incredible
you know behind the scene she provided
every support she helped organize things
and added just the execution part of the
thing so i want to thank these two
parties before i say anything in terms
of where where i was before i came into
property
well it's a long story yeah but i would
like to cut it short i came into uk uh
2009 2010
and
when i came into uk
i came with a notion of
getting myself into business
i have a vision to leave a legacy for my
family i have a vision to
join hands with
great africans who are trying to who are
working hard on daily basis to
emancipate and help africa regain
its
potential and i have this vision from
childhood
i've seen poverty i don't talk about
poverty i've seen it i was born into a
family where
from childhood i i know what it means to
be wretched
you understand and
i've seen people die in situations that
we are avoidable
people have died in my hands
and
the pain
of the fact that this death are
avoidable
has been living with me from childhood
and i've always been set on this path
to live a legacy that will help us
when i meet us i mean my immediate
community my people in africa to know
that
there are a lot of potentials we can
we can work on
to bet live a better life
so that has been my drive beyond me
doing this for for my wife of course to
keep the family happy and leave a legacy
for my children the greater african
situation is the major drive for
everything i do so when i came into uk
it was intended for me to
dive into international level and
practice engineering thinking that i
could engineer myself to that part of my
legacy which never happened
so i never had anything to do with
property
actually when i came to you can i
realize how people buy property in uk
you know you buy with you buy a house i
begin to pay my mortgage until you die
and things like that it kind of puts me
off
i never was saving to buy property i
never did at some point my wife was like
let's just buy a property i said no i
want a business
i want a business that will be
successful
that will help me to
to kind of
live the life i want to live and if i
want to buy a property i'll buy it and
pay it off i don't like to owe people
and
carried on on that but that with the
kind of work i was doing i was having
modest jobs
uh
it wasn't happening i wasn't having time
for myself i wasn't having time for my
family
i was getting frustrated by the day
and it got to a point where i told my
wife look
by the grace of god something must
happen
but
i don't know what is going to happen but
i was convinced deep inside me that
something must happen how it was going
to happen i don't know and then what i
started doing was i started going out
for business so i wasn't i was no longer
waiting
because before then i was always
changing from one job to the other job
you know you have a little increase in
salary jump from one employer to the
other one thinking that you're going to
find it a kind of a better place that we
lead you to the kind of life you want to
live but that never happens so i started
looking for business
try those sort of things i saw cass as i
registered myself so i started pulling
cars from auction
so it's not my first time dealing with
action so i started pulling cars from
action
i do them up
and said and part-time was to keeping my
full-time job
that got me bound because i wasn't
having time to to do it properly maybe
when the car is ready uh and people want
to view it i might not be in the house i
might be at work so it is a kind of
affected business
that got me bumped on that one i jumped
into something else which was quite a
very big jump at a point i i partnered
with with a friend
we
we we
registered an oil and gas company as a
oil and gas exploration company and we
wanted to kind of have
our footprint in uh in uk
we made a few attempts to secure oil and
gas wells in aberdeen it's not it's not
a cheap
vision we pursued it about a couple of
years uh again that didn't work out for
some reasons and got burnt on that one
as well and
so
that has been the background of i have
been in pursuit of what can i do yes
to achieve my legacy to leave that
vision that has been burning in my heart
from childhood
and then i it happened that a friend of
well he became a friend but he said a
new
employee in my office who we just
connected
he was new we connected and we
it happened that he was thinking
we were thinking similarly
so whenever whenever we go out for lunch
we we discuss about
all these guys who are having all these
because who are having time for their
families who are rich there must be
something they're doing that we're not
doing yeah you understand so we're
having very positive discussion
very constructive this discussion and
we started opening up to each other and
what he did for me which is significant
was that he told me that a book is read
which has helped him in his thinking
maybe i may want to read that book
and i said which book is that he said
reach that product by robert kiyosaki
he actually gave me his own copy
i asked me to read it
now i didn't read that book i studied it
by studying it i was like
i put myself in the shoe of robots and
everything he went through
you know where he talked about access
and liability trading a time for money
and all of that
i remember once i was going back from
work reading that that book in it on the
train when i came across where he
started talking about property
and
i kind of
at that page i put a stop
and i said i need to take action
mind you
like i said when i came into this
country property i was put off with
anything property because of the way
they buy property here so i have no clue
about anything property yeah but when i
read that book and i i began to see the
possibility
that lies in property you understand
that's okay let me give it a go so what
do i do normally my kind of person is a
person if i want to do anything i like
to get myself trained
and i started searching for trainers
when i searched for trainers i will
mention the number the name of the
company that came up first and i
attended their crash course in heathrow
the next saturday
yeah
went there this was michael's or someone
else it's not your course okay i didn't
pick you first
no i didn't pick you
i wouldn't mention the name but they
came off first i attended a course in in
heathrow the next weekend i just came
home i said i told my wife look i'm
going for this training i think i should
switch business this property of a thing
is is what is a kind of taking the bus
for now i want to go for the that's a
free course i've seen for saturday next
week and going for it so we canceled
three appointments and i was there i
actually attended it with my daughter
yeah with my uh my my little daughter
because i want to start kind of grooming
them from from from childhood as well so
i got got in there
it was a good event
but because of i'm a very passionate
person if i'm speaking to you if i'm in
an environment where there's no enough
energy positive energy i don't i don't
easily connect yeah so because of it i
couldn't connect i felt like they
couldn't these guys could not take me to
where i want to they may give me the
knowledge but it will just dissolve like
eyes
you understand
so i came back home and my wife was like
how did you guys say you weren't fine
but i'm not going with them i'll look
for another trainer
that's the same evening
i kind of went to youtube and said
property to the nurse in uk
you popped up
i want to be honest with you when you
popped up i'm like
not this person no
that was the first thing i said but i i
noticed that you have loads of videos so
he must be doing something right to have
all these videos
and i clicked on one i can't remember
exactly the one i clicked
you almost jumped on my face
your energy was like
boom
i told my wife this guy
is the guy that will take me
and i i couldn't even finish the video i
went to your link and book for the crash
course and i came to the crash course on
the i think 18th 19th of october at
cumberland um
around hardpack and what year was this
this is 2019 right
that was a crash course i attended
and when i when i came to the crash
course
i was
overwhelmed
i was
so excited i was so pleased
i mean the experience is
something that i remember coming to you
on that sink crash course and i told you
like
i lack words to describe you and the
impact you had on me on that day
and that is because that is what that is
what it was
because
the environment
the ambiance of positivity yeah
that characterized the crash course
was a kind of
an opportunity
for the time i've been in uk i've never
seen such environment
and it kind of sparked
something in me that was asleep
you understand yeah and
since then it hasn't stopped i think
it's like trying to create an
environment for people to be their best
version of themselves exactly
part of what we do as well as just give
people the information yeah it's also to
get them in an environment where they
can grow and be their best selves
there's only having people in the room
that are doing deals and making money
and it's hard to explain but i think
that's just as important
as the information is making sure that
there's implementation of the
information sure without the right
environment yeah your vision could die
on your lip right
and the good thing about the academy the
good thing about the cash costs
is it just gives you that environment to
thrive yeah if you have if you are ever
convinced and willing to do it there's
no reason not to do it yeah because the
environment is there it's like going to
plant a crop in a wrong environment in
acidic soil it's not going to grow
yeah but place it in a very
nice soil it will just begin to grow so
the knowledge is there the right
environment is there so important
there's no excuse one of the things i
say a lot is the environment is stronger
than willpower sure because if you if a
lot of people want to be successful and
they're trying to they're trying to hype
themselves up and they're trying to get
themselves motivated but actually you
need the right information but you need
yourself it around the right people to
be able to thrive and grow yeah so what
was it then that made you make the
decision number one to get into property
i know you said rich dad poor dad
changed your mind the book changed your
mind
about property investment
what was it that made you think actually
property is a good investment as opposed
to thinking i don't want to do property
well like like i said i was at the point
where i was looking for anything
that could lead me to the part of my leg
of the legacy i want to give division
anything any business that will work
like i am an engineer uh
the way i want to practice engineering
is such that i will practice it but
still have time for my family we still
have time to reach my community the
people i want to support and help you
understand that is the kind of
engineering i want to practice at the
moment i don't have time for myself
it's not all about making money to just
feed your family that's
that's a frustrating life for me so
property is the vehicle so the
property when i read that book and their
last property that property is say means
i could get there and i came to your
crash course and connected with
your team
and there and then i signed up to the
academy yeah the sender attended the
crash course for the day i signed up
with academy and it's good to know that
to tell you how i was moved i signed up
with my credit card i didn't have money
so you went so you went into debt to do
the training yeah
because at the end of the day i don't
want to
i don't want to do it and stop
yeah i want to do it so badly
you know it's les brown who would say
that anything that is worth doing is
worth doing so badly until you learn how
to do it well here's a question for you
in a seater october 2019
that that was around about the time of
period as well when i was getting told
stop getting people into debt to getting
training right yeah around about the
same kind of time
some people could have seen you as a
vulnerable person right you've having to
put the money on your credit card you've
got family depending on you not just in
the uk but family in nigeria you've got
a dream
to become financially free yeah you want
to leave a legacy you want to help
change the world
what would you say that because for me
it's really difficult because someone
like who's in when i started out in
property i didn't have any money right i
had to put money on credit cards borrow
money from people and just pray that it
worked and put my all into it there's
some people that could
come on the training that could put them
onto it and it might not work there's no
guarantee anyone's going to get rich
anyone's going to become financially
free there's no guarantee so
it's for me as a trainer and as a
business owner that not only runs a
property a property company but also a
property training company
how do i as a trainer
know whether to take somebody on or not
as a student well i think it's that's a
great area and it's quite a difficult
one but for me in my own opinion
i believe that every adult
every adult
should be able to take responsibility
for the decisions they make
i didn't consult you when i use my
credit card
it was my decision
to do
it it's like let me put it this way let
me let me create a scenario say like
i'm climbing i'm on top of a tree
yeah and there's only one branch
that i could hold my hand without
falling down
and i can only see one branch at a time
it's my decision to either grab that
branch
hoping that it's not gonna break so i
don't fall
or leave it and fall
whatever decision i make at that point
is my is i have to take responsibility
that's the way i see life you understand
but at the end of the day
when people make decisions and try to
look for who to blame i don't really
think it's right
if that makes sense yeah so and i always
like the narrow things to myself if i
have
like i said i've done uh
i've saved money put it into car
business
i lost
a lot of money there at fact i think i
had to clear about sea salt or five
vehicles when i wanted to close it down
and i had to sell a leatherman at half
price yeah it's my money it took me it
took me it usually takes me long to save
a thousand pounds but i lost those money
it is my decision
i attempted in those business i ventured
into them i didn't consult anyone anyone
allows them money it's my decision i'm
not going to stop blaming blaming anyone
i went into
establishing an oil and gas exploration
company it got me bumped
you know it's funny but that is that is
the truth those are the decisions i've
taken in life yeah you understand that
part of my history you understand but in
as much i've lost money there i didn't
lose everything i gained a lot of
experience i gained a lot of strength
and again from us so it's all about
taking responsibility and for us as a
company if we said you know what we
don't feel comfortable taking you on and
even if someone like you've got fire got
passion
the bank says they can afford it it's
your credit company yeah that's that
gave you the money no we didn't we
didn't we didn't put you into debt right
no you did you didn't and i don't think
actually even if you want to do it not
to take from people like myself
you still find it difficult because if i
really want to do it i can still do it
yeah
the only reason if i come to why are you
going to ask me to know that i'm in
depth if i don't want to disclose it to
you you're not going to know we can't
now
i can i can put the cash yeah for my
credit card into my into my debits i
still pay you off all we can do is give
you the best training yeah give you the
best support
and hope that you put the effort in and
it works only and of course on the
advanced training like you're on the
academy
it's not just you're not a one-off no
when you're around other academy members
most of them are winning most of them
are doing deals the academy is
what is the right word to describe the
academy academy is a wonderful place to
be it's not just
you
offering the training the kind of people
is a kind of selection of certain
character of individuals
very positive minded full of energy
chasing one goal
how to do they want to achieve their
vision they want to leave a legacy
and they have the big heart to send a
helping hand to any of the colleague
that is a kind of dropping yeah that is
what i see that is my experience of the
academy i mean
even even some people are considered to
be senior members of the academy in the
sense of people who has been there
before people like us i mean i could go
and mention their name like you know
anthony wilmot
james armstrong uh alistair connie am
rick amanda
members of your team tony cook every one
of them at every point in time
you know tom uh is it tom tom cook as
well every one of them they're happy to
have
when you're an environment where people
are happy to help you to succeed what
else do you need
you have the right knowledge
you happy you have people who are
willing to help you the only thing that
things don't don't work for for me from
what i i see people who complain is when
people don't take the right action for
instance you're saying you haven't found
a deal and in a month you have only
viewed one house
right it doesn't happen
with myself with myself
having my full-time job
which is quite busy very big one thing i
don't like about my current job is
pleasure the pressure there is doesn't
allow me to
even attend to my family and it's
worrying you understand now i don't have
time
i don't even have money i'm not able to
have savings
that's the thing when you came you were
like
my situation was awkward how did i know
you were going to be successful i tell
you how i mean you're going to be
successful you didn't have time zero
time you're really busy in a job you've
got four kids yeah you didn't have money
you had to go into debt to come on the
train right you didn't have lots of
things you had zero experience yeah you
know anything about property you've got
a history of failure yeah your other
businesses have failed yeah the reason i
knew you were going to be successful and
i told you at the time i said you're
going to be successful is because you
had a good energy
yeah you had great energy you said that
yeah i said that you you you light up a
reality
in your actual world you actually say
that or sister i see you becoming a
sunshine in uk right
yeah yeah you'd walk into a room you'd
light the room up you you'd pull
everybody up you know you just had a
great energy great belief yeah i think
belief's really important and also
you're a hard worker and you know i said
to you you're gonna be successful i
remember a few months into the academy
and you came up to me and you said
samuel i'm really struggling i
understand everything i've got the
training i've got the support i ain't
got the time i literally haven't got
time to book any viewings yeah we sat
down together and uh we put a plan
together yeah that i that that plan i
forgot to bring it today it's actually a
piece of paper i haven't thrown it away
for your information and that plan was a
game changer because what he did that he
did for me was it's streamlined
because with me
i understand like i said i understood
every of the strategy
and i started off trying all of them
yeah
and he told me hang on stop
choose one
for cash flow
that suits your circumstance yeah and i
said service accommodation i say put all
your energy there right and that was the
game changer and once once i did that i
had my first deal uh
you got it really quickly yeah yeah i
got it quickly and
you you you were my first guest in the
first one yes i came inside there yeah
and which was lovely and quite
encouraging and
after then i then decided
to take two months leave from office
without pay
and level myself into property and see i
kind of
expanded a little bit like a financial
freedom challenge is that something like
that boom so and once i did that within
the two months i was able to ramp it up
from one to five wow and then got back
to work which i'm still doing and those
five properties i know some months
they're crazy and you might make like
six thousand pounds of profit yeah but
generally speaking average out you're
talking about a profit of 3 000 pounds a
month
which is financial freedom yeah yeah it
is yeah we had a conversation recently
and you said to me look i'm making
enough money to leave my job now yeah
i'm financially free
i need to talk to you should i leave my
job what did i say
that that chat what you said was uh you
advised me because of the the
the people who depends on me my
immediate family the people who depend
on me from for my back in my country in
nigeria as well
and the laws i have
it will advise me to rather
not live now
but
see how or he said if i can get a
pattern job maybe try and see if i can
get a part-time job yeah that will keep
me going so that i don't jump out
because service accommodation is
in as much as is a working strategy it
has loads of risk
yeah given that i'm a family person that
has a lot of dependence
so you you advise that
i should calculate it very well and know
the right time to live exactly because
the thing is if someone's single and
they've got a job that they hate and you
actually really enjoy your job i know i
enjoy my job the only thing i don't like
about my job is the pressure and lack of
time right because if you went full-time
in property tomorrow you'd probably
double your your your income could you
have more time yeah yeah sure but i said
to you after we looked at it we said
look you've got four children you've got
a wife you've got people and you
in
nigeria depending on you yeah why don't
you just wait another six months
continue to build get that three four
thousand pound a month get it up to ten
until it's like ridiculous to you to
stay at your job but right now your job
um is is safe
and
it your your you don't wanna be a
situation whereby you quit it and then
suddenly over january february your
service accommodation dries up a little
bit and your income's one and a half two
grand and you're struggling and you're
stressed to pay the bills you enjoy your
job so that's kind of the decision that
we made and um since then you've gone
off and done another two deals yeah
you've got another rent to rent you've
also bought a house on auction by
refurbished so you're definitely not
slowing down anytime soon no no that's
not stopping
the light is burning yeah like
the fire in my belly is
is too hot in the sense that i'm the
only one that understands it but at the
same time i
i'm being careful how i move yeah i
don't want to be driven by emotion at
some point i actually quoted my job i've
written my resignation
but i when i checked everything and i
kind of say
patience yeah so there's no stopping
there's no talk-up if if property
business stops to work i'll jump into
something else
like i rather want to
be seen as making everything possible
to achieve my vision than to stop and
relax and think it's it's not gonna work
yeah if it's working for mr a
there's no reason why it shouldn't work
for me that's not stopping that like
i'm convinced beyond doubts
that i'm going far in property
you know like
different people take off differently
you understand i
i'm taking my time
every hour i i have
as as extra for my full-time job from my
family i spend it on property
i i view the houses 8 p.m in the night
like i will push an agent any agent
to fit into my situation yeah so you're
doing everything possible to make it
work but the fact that you've managed to
do this alongside your full-time job i
know you booked two months off unpaid
leave but it's quite remarkable really
that you've managed to replace your
income and you've done it on top of a
very demanding full-time job as an
engineer yeah what tips would you give
to somebody that's really busy that's
not got time maybe they've got not got
any money as well what advice would you
give somebody starting out that hasn't
got time hasn't got money yet they're
wanting to get into property
my advice will be
the advice i give to myself
sometimes when you think you realize
that the situation around you might be
tough
but it might actually be that you are
the limitation
against your vision
and with that
i'm able to have a mindset that anything
is achievable
it doesn't come easy
like my full-time job sometimes i i
finish off
if i have if i work in the office i
finish around six o'clock or so come
back around eight nine i switched back
to property i worked at three a.m
and sometimes i do this from one day
till sunday seven seven days a week
without enough sleep and you've got to
burn the candle
it is
tough but if you keep your eye on the
ball
where you want to get to your mind you
walk alongside with your body and that
is just my advice so if everything is
doable don't sit back and think it's not
possible it is possible
like uh people will say if you don't do
some crazy things you remember where you
are yeah and again my other advice is
sometimes it's good to pause and
if you know you are not getting to where
you desire to be in life you've got to
check the things that are impacting you
check your environment know the things
to eliminate it's so true and also
sometimes it is hard if you've got a
full-time job especially if you've not
got a lot of money as well but a lot of
people say they've not got the time but
then they get back at seven eight in the
evening and then they just chill out
watch netflix exactly on a saturday
they'll just chill out go shopping watch
tv watch the qriket and it's like well
hang on a minute it's not about how much
time you've got it's about what you do
with the time you have got let me tell
you just because you mentioned this at
some point
i took off television in my house
disposed it
wow to keep myself focused
yeah you understand so for me it's all
about whatever it takes
whatever it takes
do it yeah
and when you are doing it
it doesn't really matter so long as
you're making a forward movement i think
it was
martin luther king the junior that said
for any vision you have
fly if you can if you cannot fly run
if you cannot run
walk if you cannot walk crawl so long as
you're making movement towards the
positive direction keep moving there
must be something in you
that keeps you moving get that and keep
moving and i think that's the reason why
i said you were going to win the fire in
your belly and your mindset and your
persistence that was what i knew you had
and i thought even though you've failed
in the past two different businesses and
even if you've not got time even if
you've got a lot of money with your
mindset combined with the correct
training and support you're going to get
through the academy i was confident that
you would make it in property and i know
you've still got way more to do and way
more you're not where you want to be but
the fact that you're making three
thousand pounds a month and you've just
bought a property as well brr that's
incredible how does it feel now having
achieved what you've achieved does it
how do you feel about looking back at
how you've changed and what you've done
how does it feel for me is i feel so
grateful
i'm
i'm in that state of mind we're thanking
you in the way i want to thank you
that's you know it's difficult to thank
you
and the the games i've heard from the
academy without sounding like a sick
offense
like a walk a sick offense
it's difficult to thank you the way i
want to thank you without sounding like
a sycophant the sycophant is saying he
said he's a priest singer
oh rocky who sings praises well yeah
yeah so you understand so
when because of the way i feel in my
heart i'm so excited because two years
ago what actually has happened in
summary it's a mind shift
i have been working hard for things to
work
but it's not just that now i find i
found an opportunity
that looks very possible but it's also
my mindset to things has changed i can
tell you before
before that crash course i don't owe
anybody i can't take if i spend one
pound in my credit card like i refuse to
increase my credit card limit yeah
if i spend one pound i pay it back
you understand all those has changed
that's it a lot of things that has seen
that this interview may not be able to
may not be able to contain and it's not
just about the money i make
i'm seeing my my vision
coming through i see myself on the path
of realizing my vision and again this
interview will not be able to
to express the things
the tears i have in my heart i have
tears they might not be visible
what are the things that drive me
uh from my family
to my community i've seen tough things
happen to me directly and indirectly
and
i'm not prepared to let go without
contributing to making a positive change
yeah and that is the drive so whatever
it takes
i'm in for it and these properties that
you've got we'll talk about the latest
one that you've bought yourself
but the ones that you're controlling
talk to me about the difference between
owning a property and controlling your
property
when you own a property
i believe mind controlling controlling
is where you take a property you do not
own
you control it use it for
for for business and make money out of
it and then settle whoever owns the
property at the end of the day
it has lesser risk in terms of in terms
of capital involvement yeah like for
instance i do service accommodation
business
if i'm to buy a a normal house in london
in in sorry where i do my service
accommodation or even birmingham or
postmod where i have my units
i'm going to be spending thousands of
pounds doing that but with a little
amount of
less than 8k you're having a decent
service accommodation business that is
able to give you a return a very
wonderful return on your investments so
that is control yeah so you're
controlling another person's
uh property and you're making cash flow
and a nice control so for me
control is more interesting
than owning a property however
there are other strategies you can
deploy to on a property like the the brl
that i'm doing i'm literally going to
buy a house
that is worth 120 000 just for 10k
at the end of the day it's all about
applying the strategies yeah so
uh controlling properties with service
accommodation
you've had some of your landlords in the
past that have seen what you're doing
they've seen how much money you're
making from their properties they've got
a little bit jealous and then when the
contract when the turn ends they've said
i want it back now i want to do it
myself yeah but when they do it
they can't make money doing it on
service accommodation they put it on
airbnb and it doesn't make any money
when you do it it makes loads of money
yeah what's the difference do you just
have the touch of gold on you or what's
the difference
no magic no magic to it it's just
is
every
there's a lot of work involved and if
you're not trained
you can't do it
it is tough it's a tough business you
know the fact that we are speaking about
it now it doesn't mean that it's easy
you've got to get trained if you don't
if you don't have the right the right
thing there's a lot of a lot involved
there's a lot of
things you have to do to make it work
and if you don't know how to do them you
can as well just forget it it's a
business it's a business at the end of
the day and if you're if you're not if
you don't have the right skills for it
not up beside having this skill if you
don't also have the right the right
network yeah the right team in place
you will you will lose your deposit
yeah exactly that's what it is i think
it's a bit like if you watch somebody
driving but you've never had any driving
less yeah you're hungry oh just try it
you're gonna you're gonna crash sure and
in the same way
when you're driving you need a driving
instructor and then you get good and
then you can go off and do it you've had
to learn you've paid for education when
someone watches you do it goes oh let me
have a bash
they're not gonna be able to do it no it
doesn't work that way you gotta get
trained if it was that way everyone will
be doing it yeah yeah you've got to get
yourself trained and
spend sometimes soak the knowledge yeah
practice it you know take all the notes
all the rejections yeah you know uh get
all the initial failures
and then strengthen your muscles and
then get on that's what it is where are
your five service departments i have
today in birmingham
birmingham i have one in in uh postmods
portsmouth which is a massive one how's
that going it's going well it's not like
a church it's a church that was
converted into into decent duplex
apartments nice yeah uh it's doing well
and we have one in in stains it's just
close to heathrow and we've just taken
another one now in just beside windsor
castle oh very nice yeah so that make
your profit a little bit higher once
that one goes yeah yeah how much are you
expecting to make off of the winsor one
uh no usually we
we try to be very very conservative we
pick all our profits minimum 500 yeah
but obviously depending on the month and
the season is there always a kind of a
siege you know expanding contrast 500
pound
min
yeah yeah and that's what it needs to be
yeah that's what you know that's where
it needs to be yeah to be a business and
then the the property you've just bought
you said that you're only going to end
up leaving about 10 000 you basically
own a nice 120 000 pound house yeah for
just 10 grand yeah how how can you have
a house for just 10 grand right so it
all goes back to the training uh it's
the strategy we apply i applied on that
one is the brl strategy where you buy a
house that is run down that has good
potential for you to add value so you
buy it
a little bit lower than the actual value
if it's done up and then you're able to
add those put those values uh like you
know add kitchen add
do general reform
create other extra rooms maybe
do some extensional things like that
although we're not doing extension on
this one add all those values to push
the value up yeah and then you'll be
able to kind of pull your money out when
you refinance and then go again and do
the same strategy on another house so
what happens is at the end of the day
it's
you leave little amount of little or
nothing you know uh
little or nothing in in the in the deal
i mean we had a deal a day which was
supposed to we were supposed to pull out
all our money
and still have some profit in it but you
know that that will go up on that one
let's talk about that deal
it's important to talk about the
failures as well as the successes yeah
school is school you know you were
buying a house it was a joint venture
yeah and
you got a really good price yeah 95 000
pounds yeah but then at the very last
minute they were like actually we're
going to put the price up sure and you
were like absolutely no way yeah and i
know you were tempted to buy anyway i
was i wouldn't let you yeah yeah but you
won't let me and i i really love the
support you gave me then because what
has happened is it's my first experience
i never believed that anything anything
like that would happen i mean we are
just close to exchanging
and then they were like we need extra
money
and that just
rocked
the deal
yeah i'm i'm like anyway we have
spent some money into it
50 50. should we go or not
yeah and you are like no discipline your
disappointment yeah you know and i did
it and i'm happy i did today yeah and
it's uh it's a kind of helped me also to
build that emotional path as well to be
strong what do you mean by that
what when you when you when you are
attached
to
to a particular property because if you
feel initially when you have a deal that
is good like it was a cracking deal
so on
unconsciously you kind of build that
attachment that this is a deal i'm gonna
do this
you have an a kind of an image
of what is gonna be in the next 34
months yeah you're going to own a house
for free or something like that and
suddenly someone is like no i need
you're already emotionally attached to
it because of the picture you have
created yeah now getting out of that
emotion it's always a difficult thing to
do and uh
you need some support at that point to
be able to pull out you know if you
haven't had that experience it's that's
a chance you kind of delve into
something that you should have not yeah
not dive into it's a trick that people
use you know they'll they'll try and
negotiate just before you complete on
the property yeah and they'll know that
they'll know that you're emotional yeah
and that's why i always say never be at
ease until you've got the keys sure
right and and you're not buying a house
to live it you don't need to be
emotional it's an investment and so
formulas not feelings so we looked at
the property i looked at that it's a
great deal then you will go you went
ahead with it then you came back you
said they've changed the price yeah i
said
pull out cards yeah pull out but now you
found another property have you got the
keys oh yeah i've got the keys yeah so
now you can be at ease yeah
of course
that property as well that was an
auction property it's an action property
and it's our first time you're in action
yeah again with auctions number one
piece of advice have the absolute
maximum you're prepared to bid yeah
before you stop bidding and never go a
penny above that sure i i had that
because you you told me how you
beat for your for your castle yeah yeah
so i land for that one so yeah i wasn't
gonna exceed what you have cut so what
was the maximum price you were gonna go
up to 73 73. yeah what did you end up
getting it for 72.
brilliant so bought it for 72 000
refurbish it
how do you know how much the refurb's
going to be and how much the end value
is going to be
before you've even done it well the env
for the end valley if you've got to do a
lot of research you've got to look look
at soda comparables in the area you've
also got to speak to a lot of local
agents and locals as well for me i don't
just speak to the local agents i also
speak to local people living who own
houses around the area yeah and
obviously do a lot of digging online uh
i use a lot a couple of software pro
property data
zoopla right move you know and when you
do all those analysis then you do a kind
of a critical analysis of what is
possible being pessimistic that is the
only time i when i'm stuck in deus i can
afford to be pessimistic you have to be
yeah you're too pessimistic now you're
very conservative yes i am
but but the refurb on that you expected
about 20 25 grand end value you've
already got a chartered value will give
you an n value of 120 120 yeah so i get
that when you finish the work you're
gonna refinance it and pull out the
majority of your money believe about 10
grand then yeah but where did you get
the money from in the first place to buy
the house so we use bridging what we
call bridging finance right so it's it's
similar to mortgage but the only
difference is a short-term loan yeah
where you kind of leverage on on on on
that loan they cannot be able to pay pay
for your uh
for your debt and have you also pulled
in a joint venture partner yes i'm i'm
working with a john valencia partner on
this one who are you working with a
member of the academy oh brilliant yes
and that's the thing is it's not just
what you know it's also who you know
it's only yeah so i mean you know those
are the benefits of the of being at
academy you can always uh have jv in the
academy as well yeah these are people
who want to invest and once they see the
right deal you know they're happy to
work with you and that's what i'm what
i'm doing at the moment so with all of
what you've learned and done over the
last two years if you were advising
yourself two years ago what would you
say to yourself starting out to give
them the best words of wisdom
don't waste time
just
take
a leap from the cliff and develop your
wings as you're flying down
yeah
just
go get trained first
believe in yourself
everything works anything you can
conceive and believe works yeah
the word in the world everything happens
in our mind
get your mind your mind set right yeah
and pursue any dream you have in your
head absolutely yeah the world is
waiting for you that's my advice that is
the advice i'll be i'll give my to
myself yeah and
and that's it
what's the biggest thing that you've
learned through the academy
the biggest thing i've learned through
the academy is
with the right people around you
everything is possible yeah yeah
and what's it been like working with me
oh
like i said
it's difficult to talk about
you without sounding like a sycophant
yeah
working with you has been incredible
your passion
is so inspiring
you know your your
your belief
in what you do
touch his hearts
and
i call you a legend for a reason
i don't just call you a great man i call
you a legend and that is not me trying
to sing praises for you
it is how much you have impacted me
yeah and
i'm not able to describe the way i feel
because we have caused a very big mind
shift for me
and i repeat the benefit now so working
with you with your passion
with your energy
is what really connected
before i came to your class a crash call
like i said i was already connected with
you without seeing you yeah that passion
that's
honest desire to help people succeed
stands out among their contemporaries i
appreciate it and i just want to say as
well the feeling is mutual you're a
legend it's been incredible working with
you over the last couple of years thank
you and i've really enjoyed it and you
know what the journey continues i know
you've got a lot more that you want to
achieve sure a lot more people you want
to help but even just by coming on this
interview now you're going to be
inspiring thousands of people because
your story is incredible what you've
done starting with no money with no time
but just with a dream and ready to take
actions incredible we've got another
train and academy training tomorrow
which we're going to be running and all
the people coming they're all doing
deals
you know like i think about 80 of people
coming on the train tomorrow
are
making money in property so you know
environment what you i think the biggest
thing you've talked about today which
has been incredible is just the power of
being around the right people who you're
around is who you become yeah and it's a
pleasure to be around you and i'm
excited about your next two years we'll
definitely do a part two in another year
or two anytime any day the reason
ideally i normally will not put things
in the public but because i had to drag
you yeah you had to drag me to do this
one but the reason why i'm also doing it
is basically to inspire people not not
for anything else
because
if i never knew about you
me i may have not have been inspired by
anything to do what i'm doing today so
it's all all about impressing it upon
people that it is possible yeah that's
great well
thank you well deserved success you've
got a beautiful family thank you so much
big heart thank you deserve everything
that's happened guys i hope you found
that inspiring if you did why don't you
leave a nice comment below for a seater
also hit the like button if you want to
come along to the property investors
crash course like i said did two years
ago guess what you can come down for
free on the house because we're on a
mission to help as many people have the
finances to be able to live the life
that they deserve and this is having a
positive rippling effect across the
world and across people's hearts and
lives so if you want to come down to the
property invest scratch course leave
i'll leave a link get booked on for free
in the description and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel watch more
interviews more videos like this and i
look forward to seeing you real soon at
the property versus crash course god
bless
[Music]
you